لطالما كانت تصوير حرفه تشبه لوحه الرسام
وريشه الساحره لكن بادوات مختلفه تتنقل
بين المدن والطبيعه والمجسمات المختلفه
بما فيها البانوراميه
[موسيقى]
ولعل اكثر انواع التصوير اهميه في وقتنا
الحالي هو تصوير الصحفي الذي يعتمد على
اقتناص الفرص وسرعه المصور ونبهته وخاصه
اذا كان يعمل في المجال العسكري الذي
يتطلب قدرات كبيره في اختيار اللقطات
اللافته
[موسيقى]
ان تشاهد مره واحده افضل من ان تسمع 100
مره انا ارتور سركسيان امارس التصوير من
السماء منذ 35 عاما بعد ان خطو مجال
الطيران بالمقاتلات
[موسيقى]
تاريخي في عالم الطيران بدا منذ الطفوله
عندما حظيت بطائره لعبه وكانت المفضله
بالنسبه لي بعدها درست علوم الطيران وكان
حلمي ان اصبح طيارا وتمكنت من فعل هذا على
طائرات الميج
وتمكنت من دمج هاتين المهنتين وقررت بدء
التصوير من السماء
[موسيقى]
وساعرفكم الان على الطرق التي اتبعتها
عندما لم تكن كاميرات الاكشن موجوده
[موسيقى]
هذا اول مجسم صنعته وربطته بحامله القذائف
اسفل جناح المقاتله في الداخل وضعت كاميرا
عاديه وقمت بالتقاط اول اللقطات في مسيرتي
[موسيقى]
الاكثر تعقيدا كان هذا المجسم الذي يعتبر
مقدمه ضوء الطائره وموقعها على المقاتله
في هذا المكان
[موسيقى]
هذا الهيكل صنعته للمقاتلات النفاثه ووضعت
فيه نظام حمايه عالي المستوى ضد درجات
الحراره والهواء السريع وكان عباره عن
غطاء صلب مع زجاج متين وغير رفيع تم
تجريبه بنجاح على جسم المقاتله ميكس 29
ومن ثم تم اضافه كاميرا من طراز 360 والتي
علقت فيما بعد على هيكل محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
كان لابد من العمل على حل ثلاث معضلات وهي
الحمايه من سرعه الطيران والهواء والضغط
العالي التخلص من الحراره الناتجه عن عمل
شاحن الكاميرات بالاضافه الى تركيب بطاريه
تعمل لفتره اكبر لضمان عمل الكاميرات اكبر
وقت ممكن
سنقوم معكم بتجهيز وتركيب وتجريب هذا
الهيكل الذي يمنحنا طاقه اضافيه عبر هذه
البطاريه المنفصله عن الكاميرا لنحصل على
ساعات من التصوير خلال مرحله الطيران
تستمر الى 60 او 7 ساعات من العمل
[موسيقى]
تقول الحكمه والحقيقه هي اول من يقتل في
الحروب والازمات لذلك يعتبر الخبراء ان
توثيق مجريات الاحداث له اهميه بارزه
بالرغم من انه سلاح ذو حدين بين الحقيقه
والخداع خاصه ان تداول الصحافه في الوقت
الراهن عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول
العالم الى قريه صغيره عبد الجواد الرشد
لصباح العربيه من سماء مدينه كالوجا